here's the thing there's a question
about Free Will and and then see this is
the thing there's all that's happening
right now is just sounds if you were a
dog would you have a question about free
will or determinism or any of that
conceptual
is just conceptual
masturbation all it is is philosophers
and scientists and spiritual people are
all just masturbating to each other's
dicks and clits that's all that it is a
dog has zero
questions be a dog
woof that's your
answer the zero questions the zero ideas
of that innocent
baby it's just wholeness that's all it
is there's no stupid questions or ideas
none of of
them oh my God are there levels of
consciousness no you dumbass does a dog
ask that question no no there's
not there's not you can create endless
stories about levels of consciousness
and attainments and Journeys and all
kinds of conceptual dualities and you'll
spend in you'll spend forever forever
forever symbolizing
forever symbols are
endless symbols are
endless and a dog doesn't give a